la ministra de relaciones exteriores
australiana pennywing rechazó las
críticas de China a los submarinos de
propulsión nuclear que Australia le va a
comprar a Estados Unidos como parte del
Pacto de seguridad augus firmado con ese
país y con Reino Unido lo hizo en una
entrevista con el diario de Guardian en
la que wong defendió el plan de
seguridad y aseguró que está muy claro
que Australia no está adquiriendo armas
nucleares y que la motivación es la paz
según ella nadie quiere ver una escalada
de las tensiones ni tampoco un error de
cálculo En una conferencia de prensa el
ministro de defensa de Australia Richard
Mars dijo que no hay una intención de
operar con armas nucleares desde suelo
australiano y reiteró el compromiso del
país de cumplir el tratado de rarotonga
que establece una zona libre de armas
nucleares en la región del Pacífico está
previsto que en los próximos 30 años el
país gaste unos 368 mil millones de
dólares australianos equivalentes a 245
mil millones de dólares estadounidenses
y a 228 mil millones de euros en este
programa que según el gobierno creará
veinte mil puestos de trabajo la
adquisición convertirá a Australia en El
séptimo país con submarinos de
propulsión nuclear junto a Estados
Unidos Rusia china Reino Unido Francia e
India